Welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have to freak out about the new Batman
teaser that just dropped for the Batman
movie with Robert Pattinson we got our
first full look at the new Batman suit
in that song that's playing on that
teaser trailer is actually the Batman
theme song from the movie it'll be way
bigger in the actual movie and obviously
the main theme song will be a little bit
different but that is actual theme music
that will appear during the Batman movie
that Michael Giacchino composed
especially for this teaser trailer he
even posted about it on Twitter like yes
this is my music that you're hearing on
this so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Batman
and DC videos there's going to be a bunch
of Easter eggs there in the middle of
shooting the movie right now so we'll
think of some fun Batman themed giveaway
to do on all my Batman videos we'll just
start with breaking down the suit then
I'll talk about what's going on with the
rest of the movie because they have been
shooting for a little while now the
reason why they dropped this teaser
trailer or why Matt Reeves dropped it is
one to get people hyped up but also
probably because they're going to be
filming outdoors with it so all the
paparazzi are probably going to be taking
pictures of him running around in the
suit shortly and they wanted to release
an official version of this that looked
really nice it had some special music on
it rather than have everyone find out
from the janky potato quality pics from
cellphones so biggest thing first we got
to talk about how Arkham this looks so
if you played any of the Arkham games
this looks like a little more toned down
version maybe Arkham origins not Arkham
Knight Arkham Knight is like full suit
of armor this isn't quite that they
haven't officially confirmed what time
period this takes place during because
they're very nebulous with Batman series
like a lot of this is inspired by some
aspects of Batman the Animated Series
and during that series they try to be
very ambiguous about what the year was
like he has a lot of modern technology
but a lot of the cars look like they're
old-timey so I think it's going to be a
little like that during the Robert
Pattinson Batman trilogy they kind of
did that with the Michael Keaton version
of Batman 2 where some of it looks kind
of old-timey but some of it looks kind
of modern the suit itself is obviously a
big departure from the Ben Affleck
versions of his costume it actually
looks closer to the one from Batman vs
Superman where it's a little more cloth
and leathery looking than full-blown
suit of armor from something like
Justice League in a
wasn't clear this is not meant to be a
prequel to Justice League this is like
its whole own separate thing sort of
envisioned and created developed off in
its own little bubble of continuity but
I think there's the opportunity that
other movies could crossover with it in
the future in success for the most part
though this is set during a different
time period so it's not connected to say
like birds of prey which just dropped in
theaters or Aquaman or any of the other
movies that are happening right now
especially Wonder Woman 1984 you can see
that the cowl looks like it sits on top
of his head like he can pull it right
off it looks way more leathery you can
actually see the stitch lines in the
bottom about there and look at the thin
mouth line doesn't this remind you of
the jaw line in the cowl line from
Batman the Animated Series the suit
itself obviously looks a little bit more
like the Arkham origins suit the way
they're talking about the movie is it's
a little bit more of a detective noir
thriller which obviously I think is in
keeping with the tone of the music so
the music was written recently Michael
Giacchino said that he's been working on
it with Matt Reeves for the past year
they've been talking about what this new
Batman trilogy is going to be so they've
been developing this for a long time
it's not like they threw this together
at the last minute in Robert Pattinson
even said that he'd worn the bat suit a
long time ago like they developed a suit
once they were pretty sure that he was
going to be the guy the really big Easter
egg you may have noticed is actually the
logo itself so it does kind of look a
little bit like the Arkham symbol but
it's not tech that that's made out of if
you brighten the picture a little bit
because it is really dark
his Batman's symbol is actually made
from the gun that was used to kill his
parents look it's two different gun
pieces broken in half made to form the
bat symbol how hardcore is that turning
the thing that was used to kill your
parents into your symbol of fear you
don't get a great look at the rest of
the suit I'm sure once he's out on set
running around will get a much better
look at it so like I said there'll be a
lot of jenkees cellphone picks flying
around then in the next couple of weeks
I'm sure zoe kravitz also said that she
had worn the Catwoman suit we don't know
what that looks like but hopefully
they'll do a version of this kind of
teaser trailer for that whenever she's
seen on set if you didn't see my other
Batman videos that I posted for the new
movie in the last couple of months it's
basically going to be a version of long
Halloween with some changes from the
comic book one of the best Batman
stories of all time so pretty safe bet
there were some aspects of long
Halloween that they actually adapted for
Michael Keaton's Batman
movies going down the list of the major
cast members Andy Serkis
is playing there Alfred Pennyworth
probably going to be a hardcore version of
Alfred Colin Farrell is going to be
there penguin he was seen running around
with the white hair they had to explain
that's not what the penguin is going to
look like he was just walking around
with regular white hair because he felt
like it the penguin in the movie will
look very different zoe kravitz is going
to be there Selina Kyle Catwoman like I
said she cut her hair short so she's
going to look a little bit like this
version of Catwoman but we don't know
what the Catwoman suit is going to look
like yet John Turturro is playing
carmine Falcone obviously a big
character during Batman the long
Halloween Paul Dino is going to be there
Edward gnashed in version of the Riddler
if you're confused about the Edward
nygma and Edward Astin Edward Nash toon
was his original name in the comics
eventually he adopted the name Edward
nygma enigma but he started out as Edwin
Ashton so it's a little more real-world
feeling than the Edward nygma name
obviously going to be a very different
version of The Riddler than Jim Carrey
is Riddler Jeffrey Wright is going to be
playing James Gordon as Detective Gordon
because this isn't a retelling of the
Batman origin story but he is like a
Batman year one Batman year two three
version of the character so Gordon has
not yet become Commissioner Gordon yet
there's another actor Alex Ferns who's
playing Commissioner Pete Savage he was
the Commissioner before Gordon so r.i.p
him you kind of see where that one's
headed then peter skarsgård is going to
be playing District Attorney Gil Coulson
and as far as we know those are the
major Batman villains there may be a
couple other smaller ones that they
announced during the course of the film
but if you're disappointed that certain
characters didn't make the first film
like you're wondering what's going on
with the Joker during this timeline if
it's going to be this new continuity I
think the idea is is that through the
other films in the trilogy we'll meet
those other big Batman villains one of
the core things about Batman the long
Halloween is that easy is solving this
big murder mystery he's going around
town questioning all of his rogues
gallery of villains so he runs across
all them at some point there was a big
interview that Robert Pattinson did
about the Batman character how he felt
about him why he chose to become the new
version of the Batman at this big film
festival this is that clip
I really like
Matt Reeves and his set up for it. I mean
it's an interesting direction I don't
think it's something
from the comics
which hasn't been really explored yet
I mean you can do
quite a lot with it
Yeah, I mean Batman was really that the only
kind of superhero who I really had any
kind of connection with when I was
growing up and I'm
really yeah from the Tim Burton
ones, so I mean I just kind of obsessed I
I was a kid
Where were you when you learned that you
were going to be cast as the next Batman?
I think my first
day with Chris Nolan
Which is pretty insane!
Things change very quickly sometimes
he was actually working
with Christopher Nolan
on the Tenet movie they've only
just started promoting that when he
found out that he was going to be cast
as the next Batman so Christopher Nolan
did give him some pointers about doing
Batman related stuff in his new movies I
think the really important takeaway from
that is that he does respect the
character he grew up being this huge
Batman fan who isn't a Batman fan when
they're a little kid a lot of people
grow up on Batman I think most modern
Batman fans especially the ones that are
middle aged or younger grew up on Batman
the Animated Series and speaking of that
in terms of vibe even though we're
talking about a long Halloween type of
story a lot of people make comparisons
to the look and feel and tone of the
movie is Batman mask of the phantasm
which is one of the best Batman movies
of all time it just happens to be
animated so go out and watch it if you
haven't seen it yet I'm sure people are
going to be asking Ben Affleck what he
thinks about all this now he'll probably
be forced to give some sort of interview
I feel kind of bad for him hopefully
people won't harass him too much people
have already asked Christian Bale though
because he was out promoting his for V
Ferrari film when they were also
interviewing Robert Pattinson about this
so Christian Bale is actually really
excited about this new Batman stuff he
wished Robert Pattinson well he was
actually a total dude about it it was
great if you haven't been keeping up
with Robert Pattinson after he left
those Twilight movies he actually does a
lot of really good work he is a pretty
good actor I think the problem is is
that most younger fans just only know
him from that Twilight stuff so just
forget about all that stuff eventually
they'll drop a much bigger trailer later
this year
Paulie around December is when we'll see
the first really really big Batman
trailer so hopefully that'll just help
erase all that earlier stuff from fans
Minds it's been a long time
he's been in a franchise this big but
everyone just post your reactions in the
comments below and what will happen is
is I'll just keep doing Batman videos
for the movie as we get big reveals big
announcements or any teaser trailers or
looks at people's costumes right now I'm
just really excited to see what the
other villains are going to look like
and that Catwoman suit but I'm a big fan
of Matt Reeves I think he has a really
interesting spin on the Batman character
so I'm just really excited to see what
the rest of this looks like in a full
official look at the Batman suit because
this is really just part of it
if you spotted any other big Easter eggs
during this teaser trailer that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments
everyone click here for my other Batman
teaser for the Riddler character that I
did a little while ago and click here
for my brand-new Avengers infinity saga
deleted scenes thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
This is the way!